today i'm announcing several initial
steps my administration is taking
to curb this epidemic of gun violence on
april 8 president biden announced a
handful of executive actions meant to
curb gun violence
following shootings in atlanta and
boulder at the top of the list was a
proposal to stop the proliferation
of so-called ghost guns these are guns
that are homemade
built from a kid ghost guns or
unregistered firearms that weren't
assembled by licensed
gun manufacturers are sold in highly
regulated gun shops are most closely
associated with this man
cody wilson founder of defense
distributed and creator of the liberator
a 3d printed plastic gun that captured
the public imagination
3d printed guns wouldn't have serial
numbers because they could be made
entirely out of plastic they could
bypass metal detectors
defense distributed's signature product
is the ghost gunner
a do-it-yourself gun milling machine the
size of a small printer that enables
anyone with enough time and interest to
create
unregistered firearms simply by
purchasing parts online
downloading specs from an online library
like wilson's def cad and assembling the
final product
wilson says the units fly off the
shelves every time a major politician so
much as
mentions gun control as soon as biden
says hey you know in 30 days you're
going to lose your ghost guns everyone's
like
i got to buy a ghost gun you know at
some of our sites we sold out
you know 25 30 items you know like
instantly
wilson is back at the helm of defense
distributed after stepping away in 2018
when he was arrested for allegedly
paying for sex with the 16 year old
who may have misrepresented her age the
legal age for consent in texas
is 17. wilson pled guilty to a lesser
charge and is on probation
he's also had to register as a sex
offender and agree not to purchase new
firearms
every farm that i own i'm able to
continue to own so it's kind of a legal
gray area actually which
you know are the types of things i'm
most comfortable with how
easy or difficult you know has it been
to jump back into this role
i never truly left the company but to be
the public head of this company is to
face like a lot of scrutiny and that
wasn't appropriate
while i was under indictment but after
the indictment was over there was really
no
legal difficulty anymore and the county
in the state were cool so i didn't feel
like it was fair to have anyone else
face
the difficulty and the scrutiny of
running this company defense distributed
has been fighting off federal
and state legal challenges since its
founding in 2012.
biden's requested rule change is the
latest front in that legal battle
the president was vague on the details
but he has asked the department of
justice to issue a new rule
on ghost guns within 30 days wilson
anticipates that the proposed regulation
will classify
more gun parts such as the lower
receiver that the ghost gunner modifies
as firearms that would each require
registration numbers branded on them
that was the rule change proposed by the
non-profit gun control advocacy
organization
every town for gun safety which was
founded by michael bloomberg
they think if they add more components
and define more things as firearms that
require serial numbers
that means more background checks that
means less diy unfortunately
i believe it means more 80 receivers
more diy
why is that that it would have the
counter-intuitive effect
well i think we're all good libertarians
here right we recognize people who
actually respond to incentives
and so if it's actually more difficult
to buy an ar
an ar upper receiver like from psa
because it's serialized and now i got to
go to the
through the background check and
everything i'm now going to consider for
the first time
making an ar upper receiver and while
wilson was a pioneer in the diy gun
space defense distributed is now just
one of many players meaning regulating
ghost guns will be more of a challenge
just in the last year we've seen an
amazing development
of popular 3d printed kits which include
glock slides
printed smg the incredible hybrid and
mostly 3d printed gun concepts which
were far beyond like what we were doing
just a few years ago this community of
people is not limited by the law
defense distributed ghost counter we we
always kind of build our igloo
with the building blocks of the law this
other group of kids they've decided well
actually we don't we don't respect the
law at all
and they freely illegally sure but
freely share and advance this stuff even
faster
because of the opposition that companies
like mine encountered uh
leading up to even 2018 so again another
example of an acceleration
of what's an obvious technical endeavor
if you have
the right kind of machine in your garage
a raw block of aluminum is readily
convertible
into a firearm receiver i think the
interesting thing with these sorts of
laws
is there's this sort of growing gap
between
the what's on paper and what is
enforceable in law
kareem shaya is a software engineer and
co-founder of open source defense a gun
rights organization mostly made up of
engineers and silicon valley programmers
seeking to distance the debate over
the right to armed self-defense from the
left-right culture war
if you look at the path gun rights have
taken over the past
five years really that is the story of
gun rights moving from a world of
politics to a world of culture
in 2020 between seven and fifteen
percent of the people who are
gun owners today in the us became gun
owners in 2020
and the fastest growing segments within
that were black people and without
the way any network grows is kind of as
a function of
how active the nodes in a network are so
as
people join if they are eager about
getting
more people to join that compounds
really quickly and so
the more it gets away from politics the
faster it's going to keep getting away
from politics and going to this
place of just building a culture that
everyone can be part of
in the tumultuous year of a pandemic
mass protests
riots and a contested election gun sales
spiked across america and
especially in big cities the firearm
industry trade association says that
more than five million registered gun
sales in the first seven months of 2020
were to first time buyers as people
learn about guns
they tend to be cool with them i think
arguably youtube and twitter and
instagram
are the biggest advances for gun rights
of the past
several decades at least and actually
like arguably more important than any
actual gun technology in terms of
spreading gun rights
gun violence in this country is an
epidemic
and it's an international embarrassment
in the covet era the biden white house
is framing gun violence as a public
health issue
but wilson believes the career
bureaucrats at the atfe have long had
these regulations ready to go
and were just waiting for a president to
enact them joe was
simply able to take advantage of what
the atf was already preparing and ready
to do and kind of wanted to do for the
last four years so this might feel like
a kind of warp drive or acceleration
of the problem but in fact it's it's
simply the problem of not being able to
replace the permanent government
bureaucracy that's installed in dc so
biden doesn't have i think unique ideas
he's simply lent
an agency which is willing and waiting
to a more robust activist center you
know funded by bloomberg
more installed in the government like
senator mark kelly brought the giffords
desk to the senate
uh and menendez new jersey delegation
connecticut etcetera they have open
lines
uh to the executive now they're gonna
constantly be asking the atf to shop in
their wish list um if there's a real
republican party that's a big if
um surely they can stop a lot of it
legislatively but you know this is the
problem of a permanent executive staff
and
we'll always be having to watch these
rules the
old idea of how gun laws worked
was this idea that safety comes from
this central authority
what the internet has changed is well
rather than having a centralized model
about who gets to be safe and how
each person has a right
to determine how they're going to be
safe in other words
if someone is trying to hurt you you
have the right to stop them
and that's pretty uncontroversial if you
going to think about it that way
and so if you have the right to stop
them
you you have the right to the tools to
do that biden is also proposing to ban
pistol braces
and push for more red flag laws that
would allow police to confiscate
someone's firearms based on reports of
erratic behavior
from acquaintances but wilson says he
isn't particularly worried about the
effect
these rules will have on his business or
on gun rights in america
your general attitude every time i've
talked to you regarding
that question has been to say more or
less that
the technology simply outpaces the speed
at which the regulators can react
do you still feel that way or have they
now
started to catch up important ways
regulators and attorneys general have
caught up i mean they can define
the problem in the terms we specifically
began with five
six years ago but that doesn't mean that
they can accomplish meaningful
regulation of it it's kind of like you
know they're using the laws like a
talisman as a kind of
magical thinking like no one can really
understand what you're doing with your
computer where you're getting this
information on the internet everybody
knows that it's like the file sharing
wars
of the 2000s to this day you can pirate
and share anything you want online
everyone knows that so probably to
meaningfully challenge what we're doing
right now there needs to be an act of
congress
i don't see that happening in the next
couple years